I started making films because I wanted
to see paintings move painting led to
cinema all I wanted to be was a painter
all I wanted to be was a painter so I
studied painting at the Boston Museum
School in the Pennsylvania Academy of
Fine Arts I was working on a painting of
a garden at night and I was sitting
looking at this painting and from the
painting I heard a wind
and then I saw the green start to move
and I said oh a moving painting
to
see what that did the world boom it can
jump if the right sound is married to
that picture so Cinema to me is sound in
picture moving together in time and for
me it was born out of painting